[Music]
gomez didn't go to the Fashion Awards
but she was busy putting on the style
display Oliver owned with sex yep
countable six changes in one fabulous
night so Selena was hand in hand with
the weekend for a dinner date at Rao's
one of New York's most famous Italian
eateries
stopping he posed with fans her gray and
cream flip dress was just one of the six
outfits the singer worn one day for day
of press interviews outfit number one
was this navy blue asymmetrical number
four number two she donned this long red
sleeveless colored dress with a thigh
high slit number three Selena went short
and his black and white mini an mo vibe
was look number four the bright pink
jumpsuit had parents on the prince and
sequined cats on her left shoulder
number five was a summery stripe to slip
dress that she tucked off with a black
motorcycle jacket amber number six her
date night the Mimi wait dress had black
lace trim along the plunging neckline so
six different outfits but she did
recycle her shoes Selena chose these
strappy Louis Vuitton sandals with
transparent heels for four off her six
looks
[Music]
you